Good morning Hank, it's Tuesday!
Hank, you were just greeted by people in Schaumburg, Illinois, where I've been visiting.
Now I'm driving home, and I'm filming Brotherhood 2.0. while driving. Is that safe?
No! It's not safe! But if I don't film Brotherhood 2.0 while driving, when will I film it? I'm gonna get home right before midnight.
Observation: people in passing cars look at you funny when you're driving down the road holding a camera in front of your face.
Anyway, Hank,
I have to publicly state that I do not recommend video blogging while driving at 72 miles an hour.
Unless you are nine months into a 12-month project and have not yet missed a day in that project.
Okay Hank, I just pulled on merging traffic.
Hank, I just passed an outlet mall, and I was like who goes to outlet malls anyway?
And there was a billboard that said "At the outlet mall, come see the beef jerky outlet!"
And I was like, "oh my god, must get over, must get in the right lane, must exit now!"
But then there was this tragically long line of semi trucks, and I wasn't able to exit,
so I missed the beef jerky outlet! I mean Hank think of the beef jerky deals!
We should have more awesome outlets like that.
Maybe we can go to Winner, South Dakota and build like a nerdfighter outlet mall.
We could have like a "Put Stuff On Your Head" outlet that would sell like
85,000 different items that will fit on top of your head at wholesale prices. Of course, we'd have to have a Peeps outlet.
They'd sell like every possible color of peeps, stamped into every shape and size in the world.
By the way, Hank, my lifelong dream? A peep in the shape of me.
And of course there would have to be a pants outlet, and as I envisioned it Hank all the pants we sell in our pants outlet would
be emblazoned with pineapples. The pineapple would tell you that you've got a pair of real legitimate 100% nerdfighter pants.
Why a pineapple Hank? Because it's the international sign for welcome.
It's like saying, "Welcome to my pants", and speaking of welcoming people to my pants Hank,
I'd like to thank you for getting the Brotherhood 2.0 forum "my pants" back up.
Hank, I think I'm gonna go back to driving now.
So that's it for me in Indiana, where the road is flat, the day is long and the corn is plentiful. I'll see you tomorrow.
P.S. Hank it occurs to me that we've gone nine months in this video blog, and we've never really disagreed.
So I've been thinking that maybe it's time for just a little tiny feud.
I don't even know what we could disagree about, but maybe if we can come up with something then the nerdfighters can pick who wins?
All I know is this Hank: if we do have a feud, like a pirate at a ninja convention, you're gonna get pwned.
P.P.S. Tomorrow's the yeti's birthday. Yay, Sarah! Oh, and Hank P.P.P.S., like it says on my friend Katie's arm, don't forget to be awesome.